Speaker 1: So we've been very concerned for months
now about a possible sequel to the January six
Trump riots and really ever since the organizers
started planning this event for Washington,
D.C. on September 18th, we've been worried
about whether there would be another violent
confrontation, another insurrection, a coup
attempt or whatever else the case may be.
Now, September 18th, 2021, you might
notice if you look at the calendar,
that date is now in the past. This was this past
Saturday. And the reason for the fears of violence
was that as as much as the point of the rally
could be understood and we'll get to how it
sort of wasn't even clear what the point of the
rally was. As much as we could understand the
point of this rally, it was to support what the
rally goers believe is unfair treatment of the
alleged Trump rioters from January six. The if
there was any theme and it was so disjointed,
if there was any theme at the Saturday event,
it was that the September 18th protesters
feel that those accused of of rioting
on January 6th are being held illegally
without good reason in poor jail conditions,
not being given good food or provided bail.
Suddenly, the Trump Estates care about prison
reform, hilariously, but if you are rallying
in support of rioters, it's totally plausible that
you would become violent as well. Fortunately,
Washington, D.C. was far better prepared.
Fortunately, it did not become violent. That's
good. I know that there are many on the right
saying you liberals want it to be violent. No, I
wanted it not to be violent. We even had a coupon
code during our live stream Saturday, which was,
please, no riot. We did not want it to be violent
and it was not. But hilariously, it did become a
complete and total humiliation. A few dozen people
showed up to the event. There were more media
people. Then actual protesters, the protester
attendance was in the dozens where is the media
presence was in the hundreds. Now, later, we'll
be talking about whether the lack of turnout
combined with last week's disastrous California
gubernatorial recall results are sort of signaling
a waning impact or influence of Trump ism
in the Republican Party. I'll get to that.
Let's first focus on the rally itself. Spectrum
News congressional reporter Talia Taylor Populars
posted some observations along with a
clip and noticed several hundred press,
hundreds of police and a few dozen actual rally
attendees, a couple dozen counter protesters.
Let's get into some of the rally nonsense.
Our friend Lauren Windsor was right there.
She filmed a ton of this. Here is the organizer,
Matt Brainard, explaining, I guess, the point
of the rally, which is really hard to understand.
Speaker 2: We already have poll numbers that show
essentially half of the public believes that
the government is holding political prisoners
back from Christmas and it's not it's not partizan
Speaker 1: by white rassmussen,
disastrous pollster. And they essentially
believe I mean, this is this is what we
call weasel language. Thirty five percent
Speaker 2: of Democrats agree with that.
In fact, yesterday I had a wonderful interview,
which is you can see the full livestream because
I don't follow you up to my good new friend from
MSNBC. And after the interview, a guy who watched
the whole thing. I never apologized for chemo
and started to be rather critical of questioning,
saying that it was completely misrepresenting
what this rally was about. They can't paint
every person hating a police officer with
a fire extinguisher and violence like that
or destroying doors or other property with the
people who walked in a few hours later not knowing
what they're doing. And they can't be paid.
Speaker 1: As you can see, it's it's really
not clear what this whole thing is about,
Speaker 2: the same roadblocks.
And what was interesting to me is he
said, look, I'm a liberal Democrat.
This is about this is about President
Trump fighting Republican Party,
not human rights and the civil civil
rights. And I'm going to bring somebody
up to say the pledge who's been persistent.
Speaker 1: OK, so then there were prayers and
there was a pledge and there was the reading of
letters. It it's not really clear what the whole
point of it was other than to say the alleged
rioters from January 6th are being not treated
well. Now, hilariously, Lauren Windsor, who
filmed a lot of this stuff, noticed that most
of the security surrounding Matt Brainard were
black men. She asked him about it afterwards and
he really did not like this line of questioning.
Speaker 3: Why do you have a predominantly black
security force? I have no idea. I didn't
know what a dumb question was. You know,
Speaker 1: I have no response. So you found
that to be a dumb question then. And this this
is where it starts to get into sort of outer
space. They started doing a say her name thing
with Ashley Babbette. Now, remember, Ashley
Babbitt was a trespassing criminal aggressor
on January 6th. Tragically, she was killed by
an officer. An investigation has been done.
The officer was cleared in any other situation.
If this had been an anti-war protest on January
6th or BLM or whatever these right wingers
would be say folks support back the blue,
the officer was cleared. Now there are essentially
martyring Ashleigh. Babbette, look, at this
Speaker 3: point, Ashleigh, that
he was these. And highly densely
Unidentified: populated by Ashley in Rhode Island.
Speaker 3: Thank you.
Speaker 1:
You know, they say don't glorify criminals.
They said George Floyd shouldn't be a hero.
All this stuff by their own standards.
The officer was investigated and cleared.
Ashley Babbitt was tragically killed by
police, but she was there trespassing and
in violation of the law and believed to have
been engaged in the rioting. And they would be
saying if it were anybody and if the cause
of the protest was anything other than try
to steal the election for Trump, they would
be saying the officer behaved beautifully.
So this is all wacky now then it
really got nuts in this next clip.
An angry, apparently Kuhnen woman starts to get
really angry with Lauren for covering the event.
Speaker 3: I said I'd like to know how I'm about
Unidentified: the race car from.
We love everybody.
Speaker 3: We love everybody,
red, yellow, white, all the time, we're Americans,
it's always been the melting pot of the world.
Young people absolutely hate America, the
world in America that is a to hate in America.
I don't know what kind of questions
for you. I mean, I think it's a
relevant question. And you're saying that
you're not a white supremacist rally, but
Unidentified: that's not enough. Your
mom said you don't think that was
deliberately done. No. No. OK, so I. Ready.
Speaker 3: What's the name of the security
for you? It wouldn't have any problem. You might
be his best friend. You don't look like me. Oh,
my God. My face like.
Speaker 1:
So now the woman is getting
really up and she's so close to
Lauren Windsor that she's off camera
Unidentified: for me, I don't care.
I'm we're surrounded by
Speaker 1:
OK, so so that was pretty wacky. And then one last
interesting. This was actually interesting. I love
it when there's these conflicts between people
who have sort of like an identity wrapped up in,
for example, in this case, firefighters. This is
super interesting. This is a different reporter.
Richard Hall, a firefighter in uniform, comes
over to talk to reporter Richard Hall and
starts saying the Trump riots on January
six were a false flag. It was just it was
staged, fake what you know, whatever they
mean by a false flag, that's what it was.
And then another firefighter not in uniform
overhears this and comes over and says,
this guy doesn't know what the hell he's
talking about. Look at this gentleman.
Speaker 3: You saw the bomb. You
know, every soldier of history will
prove me wrong, that that was a false flag.
History will reveal I am a firefighter, too,
and this guy is talking pureblood. There's no
question that what happened on January 6th.
Is the work of people who are supporters of
Donald Trump, right, who decided falsely and
without any proof that the 2012 election? I will
in a moment. In the twenty 20 election where you
thought it was fake for you there. I was really
I was here on game where he said to me, the man
makes a point. I want to hear you next. My name
is, by the way, brother. My name is Eric Lamar,
L.A. and they are and I'm a retired firefighter. I
would never occur to me to come down here wearing
my mom, wearing my classes. And you're going to
retire. I'm saying this is what you're seeing
right here is part of the problem. And it's so
wrong. And I almost wish to say that it is from
a highly respected fire department. This guy is
Trafton. And I have I have the utmost respect
for my brothers and sisters that afternoon.
Why are you sorry for someone who not only
is a captain, but as you can see your support
and who's coming down here today and he is great.
Speaker 1: Yep, that's beautifully said.
Beautifully said. And that's, you know,
the and the use of the guy pointing out I
wouldn't come down here wearing my glasses,
but I think that's the equivalent of like
in the military. I think it would be like
your dress uniform. I wouldn't be down here
doing that either way. And then spreading lies
under that guy's absolutely horrifying. So
what's the good news? There was no violence.
Barely anyone showed up. It's really the
best possible outcome which will get us
into our next topic today, which is whether
the influence of Trump ism is evaporating.